I'm all way too a buffalo farm in Fife
hoping that we can make Scotland's
first-ever batch of fresh buffalo
mozzarella cheese
as a nation we now produce more
mozzarella than Italy
sadly it's protest mozzarella all from
cow's milk and nothing to do with
Buffalo's milk so this from a Ches point
of view is a very exciting journey
[Music]
I'm going to mean Buffalo farmer Steven
Mitchell in five who's got me at my
sports car and into something more
suited for herding beasts that weigh a
ton Steve has been farming buffalo for
meat for three years but he's never made
cheese until today
[Applause]
we need to round them up to milk them
but they don't all move without a fight
[Music]
now we branded them up
we've got pick out the females were the
biggest others to milk but I'm a bit
distracted by the size of Stephens bull
he's monstrous what's his name
he's called Marquis come on I'm dying to
jump on him but no kicking me off he
swept me off before how do I stop him
glasses break Malky oh [ __ ] you very
doesn't try to jump back oh god they are
you talking about round
Malky so I think that was in season oh
[ __ ] okay that's quite impressive kissy
[Music]
and pitch comes go go go good I'm
knackered already and we still got to
milk the thing and make the cheese I'm
gonna let you have a shot yes you can
get some of that milk out when you're
bent down there look you may be more
worried about the the kicking I'd
watching it for the [ __ ] ready
well you're right below a bum he's had
us up from again further back okay she's
not gonna come back again come back okay
so one cue
now she's pissing oh you know your
combination [ __ ] and piss you stimulate
little organs you're just using one
finger what's good you know so you just
squeeze bringing it damn it not pulling
they all hey well guarded milk okay find
me just when I thought I got the hang of
it the milk came out in pints all over
me
where's the [ __ ] met I'm glad I do
have to tell you I've got another a p20
twice a day crazy to even [ __ ] laugh
together
once we've extracted the first bit of
milk by hand the machine does the rest
which keeps the milk squeaky-clean for
the cheese that's amazing that you know
well they say the fresher the better for
their old BOTS our army and this is
gonna be Scotland's first ever
mozzarella Stephan has called in experts
Horace and his son Mike to give us a
hand
well this is the first for me I've never
made a mozzarella ever before so we eat
the milk up to heat up to 42 degrees
yeah okay and then we're gonna add the
cultures straight to the vent the heat
up the milk and add the cultures this
starts the cheese making process
yeah so we take it off the heat leave
that to cool down now
ours are now the water in the milk
called the way separates and it's thrown
away the curd is left and is melted with
boiling water to make mozzarella process
okay good we're now turning it from curd
into mozzarella okay so we just mix it
together melting it together so I'm
kneading it together
that's it love look at that stretch out
okay forward together who is like a
giant piece of my own age need they all
need the corners into the other side
linen for your fingers sugar your
fingers now that's the way you've got it
Steve you got it that's it there we go
that's the first course once at elbow
this perfectly training yeah he's got
bigger balls I'm a big was a more
perfectly round
maturity my man maturity sit Stephens
are some friends and family over and I'm
doing a barbecue to celebrate burgers
with buffalo meat and Scotland's
first-ever buffalo mozzarella I can't
wait
beep perfect burger except this time we
lose Buffalo mania
definitely yeah so far yeah we mix the
buffalo mince with red onion mustard
garlic and a good splash of Worcester
sauce and Tabasco
a small affair with your mates they'll
get it Oh get upset yeah yeah again
yours is bigger than mine when the clerk
is are nearly done I'm going to top them
off with mozzarella yeah but first I'm
gonna use it to make a delicious salad
okay here we go
that's beautiful yeah where is their
love milk so Susan any of it dad is so
creamy
that's beautiful that I've got a really
nice feet me about this I think this is
gonna take off you know just put it on
there like that nice and then with a
beak - Martin just get it sliced season
with salt and pepper
it's all new rule extra-virgin olive oil
yeah colour the olive oil now when it
hits the mozzarella its extraordinary
and I'm just gonna chop the basil and
then just sprinkle it over there and
then finally the lemon juice just brings
it together this is the bit I've been
waiting for I swear to God might have a
little taste
oh my god Oh
it's good well done well done and clever
percentages please that is delicious
it's this fantastic absolutely I'm
speechless the other side pressures on
the pressures on again like a burger the
triggers and what's thrown on top as
well Beauty melted yeah
Scottish buffalo mozzarella done buddy
[Music]
yes unfortunately my hands still smell
of [ __ ]
[Laughter]